hello Phil encourage subscribers my name
is Daniel soul I'm a festival director
of the Holly Schwartz Film Festival just
an interview with dave and karen for
film courage hope you all get to check
it out and hope it's a formative and
helps outside of that we we all decided
Dave Karen and I that we want to give a
toughie way back you know back to the
film courage scribers and that we we
knowledge of us felt we want to give
some some free submissions to the
festival so we can give to free
submissions to the film festival for
this year our next deadline coming up is
April twelfth for the regular deadline
May twenty-fourth for the late and you
know we figured a fun way to do this is
a myself I'm an avid record collector
now of a lot of random records obscure
records good and bad and so we felt to
be good to uh to throw some records your
way and see if you can guess the the
artist behind the record first person to
answer correctly in the comment section
will win the free submission and again
we're giving away two submissions with
two separate records to showcase and
best of luck see you at Holly shorts
you